[Music]
so this has been in my cancel pile for a
few days i almost let it go because time
had passed but i can't because there are
things in life which are destined for
the daily cancellation this is one of
them it also fits in a nice kind of
symmetrical way with what we talked
about to start the show
the left trying to interpret world
events through their very narrow insular
lens that brings us to miss nicole
hannah jones who's the
new york times journalist who brought us
the 1619 project she won a pulled
surprise for her work on that piece of
thoroughly debunked agit prop because a
pulitzer these days is about as
meaningful as a teen choice award or a
nobel prize and maybe she'll win one of
those awards or all three for her
commentary on the ukraine crisis as far
as that goes jones is a little bit of a
tough spot because her mind is a vehicle
with only one gear it's a menu with just
one option a buffet where every dish is
the same she has one setting one lens
for viewing the world and it's the
racialized lens of crt
problem is that a war between ukrainians
and russians
would seem to fall outside of the crt
framework
these are two groups of europeans
fighting in a region of the world 6 000
miles away
crt has no insight to offer about such a
conflict because crt is among other
things incredibly narrow and blinkered
in its view of the of race and of the
world
in fact it basically ignores the entire
rest of the world and pretends that
everywhere is just like the modern
united states
this is how crt disciples can for
example
claim that non-white people cannot be
racist because uh racism is power plus
prejudice and non-white people don't
have institutional power
which is obviously false even as it
pertains to this country but it's even
more false across the mess the rest much
of the rest of the world
filled with countries where all of the
institutional power is held by non-white
people
there are no whites holding
institutional power in china
does that mean there's no racism in
china
that would certainly come as a shock to
anybody who's ever spent time in that
country
but these are the limits the limitations
of the modern american race hustler
and it's why jones had to struggle and
stretch to find a way to make the
ukraine situation fit into her
preconceived mold
and this was the best she could do
so in a series of tweets last week jones
made the case
that the concern for ukraine in this
country stems from anti-black racism
she tweeted quote every journalist
covering ukraine should really really
look internally this is why i say we
should stop pretending we have
objectivity and instead acknowledge our
biases so that we can report against
them many of us see the racialized
analysis and language and honestly these
admissions of shock that this is
happening in european country are
a-historical and also serve to justify
the lack of sympathy for other invasions
other occupations and other refugee
crises involving peoples not considered
white
now don't go don't don't worry it gets
much better and by that i mean by that i
mean worse she says what if i told you
europe is not a continent by definition
but a geopolitical fiction to separate
it from asia and so the alarm about a
european or civilized or first world
nation being invaded is a dog whistle to
tell us that we should care because
they're like us to be clear we should
care about ukraine but not because it's
european or the people appear white or
that they're civilized and not
impoverished
all people deserve to be free and to be
welcomed when their countries are at war
now okay
let's first engage with this idea that
europe is not a continent
she would later go on to explain that
quote the entire continent is either
asia or eurasia i suppose that's not up
to me i'm just stating a fact about what
defines a continent
yeah just stating facts sure the
interesting thing about this fact is
that it not only is not a fact but even
if it was a fact it would still be
totally irrelevant
let's pretend for a moment that europe
isn't a continent
okay i mean how does that at all impact
one way or another the relevance of the
war in ukraine
but europe is a continent because a
continent by definition is quote any of
the world's main continuous expanses of
land
europe is one of the earth's main
continuous expanses of land and so it's
a continent
now perhaps she thinks that it's not a
continent because it's connected to
other continents
but if that's the case then the only
pure continents in the world are i guess
australia and antarctica
the rest of us exist in a giant muddled
mass of connecting expanses of dirt and
rock
it's true that the lines distinguishing
europe from asia were invented by human
beings the lines are drawn on a map they
aren't carved into the actual ground for
the most part
but that doesn't make the lines
fictional
i mean dragons and unicorns are
fictional europe is real
you can go visit it i mean there are
certain parts of it that i would avoid
for now but you you could go
besides if europe is a fiction then so
is africa
that continent and all of its countries
have also been defined by lines that
human beings have drawn
in this sense
race is kind of a fiction too
people have different skin colors in
reality but we as human beings are the
ones who decided to label those colors
and imbue them with deeper significance
yet nicole hannah jones and her crt
comrades would say that it's racist
to try and erase race in that way
it used to be considered progressive and
politically correct to say that you're
colorblind and uh you know you don't see
race and race isn't real that used to be
the the progressive thing to say now
that is itself a racist claim according
to the prophets of crt
this is the problem with um
the people who go around labeling
everything a social construct
they set the precedent that a thing is
meaningless if it's a construct
but they're unwilling to apply that
precedent consistently
so what about the rest of her claim she
says that we only care about ukraine
because they're white
well that's clearly absurd just a few
months ago the big story was the
situation in afghanistan and the
disaster that unfolded because of the
way that joe biden handled the pull out
there
people were quite concerned about the
plight of afghans who are not white
now it's true
that the concern didn't seem to last
that long
but it won't last in ukraine either
people are led by the media to care
about one thing and then another than
another
as the media jumps from one lily pad to
the next there's plenty to be said about
this pattern of intense yet fleeting
focus on one thing at a time in rapid
succession but you certainly can't call
it racist
now since we're on the subject of
prejudice
i should mention that this past weekend
in dc a russian restaurant called russia
house was vandalized and spray painted
with anti-russia messages
meanwhile people are dumping their vodka
down the sink
prominent members of congress like eric
swalwell have actually proposed rounding
up all the russian students in the
united states and kicking them out
listen to this
congressman you you say a pull from a
menu of options but we heard from a
former dni clapper uh less than an hour
ago it says uh the time for and i'm
paraphrasing here proportionality
incrementalism is over we heard from the
former defense secretary william cohen
dump all the full gauntlet of potential
sanctions on putin why not do that
everything we do has to be aligned with
our allies and the fact that we were
able to get the germans to stop this
pipeline that's huge that's us
leadership
on the international stage
and so we want to move with our allies
in nato but also countries like japan
who can you know take quite
swift and severe actions against russia
but yes on the table should be
sanctioning putin personally
completely taking them out of the
european and international banking
system which is known
as swift frankly i think closing their
embassy in the united states
kicking every russian student out of the
united states those should all be on the
table and vladimir putin needs to know
every day that he is in ukraine there
are more severe options that could come
now after 9 11 uh which was an attack on
our actual country
we heard and have continued hearing
quite a lot of outcry about alleged
islamophobia
after china unleashed a virus on the
world that killed hundreds of thousands
of our own people there was an outcry
against anti-asian hate
now are we gonna hear similar
denouncements of anti-russia hatred
will the media follow these kinds of
stories with the same feverish interest
will people of russian descent be
granted victim class status
the answer is no of course
how does that fit in with nicole hannah
jones theory according to her narrative
discrimination against white people
ought to provoke the most outrage given
that she says we only care about white
people
and yet the opposite proves true once
again
that's because her narrative is divorced
from reality entirely
she may not know much about geography
but we must admit that she is an expert
on fiction and that's why today nicole
hannah jones is once again cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content